hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Game of Thrones episode 5 video
and oh my god careful for spoilers hold
the door for spoilers here we go Vegas
reveals that I totally did not expect to
get this soon revealing the true origin
of the White Walkers and how Hodor got
his name how he went from being Willis
to being Hodor
his name is different in the books so
that might mean something about the
twist on the TV show but I'm assuming
this is one of those storylines where
george RR martin gave them some advice
so hopefully there's a way to clarify
the big white walker twist as well as
the Hodor twist without spoiling winds
of winter because it's going to be a
while before that book comes out but
let's do top 10 WTF
I'll explain book changes as we go along
there were a couple book things that
happen number 10 Littlefinger resurfaces
Sansa makes him explain what he thinks
happened to her they really laid it on
thick like I said in one of my previous
videos the actor who plays Littlefinger
actively did not know what was going on
with Ramsay he feels genuinely bad about
it so he's trying to help Sansa now but
the question is is will she let him I
don't ever want to see you again but I
will take your advice and go seek my
uncle out so she's just learning the
game of Thrones why did you lie to your
brother when he asked how you found out
about that she kind of trails off she's
taking a page from Littlefinger she's
learning to play the game of Thrones her
value will be in her politicking not in
her war making like say Jon Snow he's
the guy that's going to write out on the
battlefield and decapitate people Sansa
is the one who works with Davos to find
out which northern houses they can go to
so part of the fun of the next couple of
episodes will be seeing them build their
army out and I like the way they invoke
some of the book things now there are
lot of characters they haven't done from
the books yet but they invoke the
manderlys Lord too fat to sit a horse
things that they've skipped over so far
so they are trying to include a lot of
book things it's just that in the books
around this time Stannis is still alive
he's the one that's trying to mask the
army and sends Davos around so he sends
Davos to white Harbor so in this scene
when they mentioned white Harbor it's
just a nod to that number nine WTF the
origin of the faceless people jaqen
H'ghar narrates the story of the first
faceless people in the minds of ancient
Valyria there been a couple videos I
made that have explains some of their
origins because there are some mystical
origins there are a bunch of different
slaves that were taken by the Valyrians
thrown into their minds
and the idea of the many-faced God arose
from all these different slaves with
different cultures different languages
praying to their gods people got the
idea that they might be praying to the
same God so eventually they organized
that led to revolt in the beginnings of
their order
but the way jaqen H'ghar explains it
makes it sound like it was just the
faceless people that founded Braavos
it's way more complex than that what
happened is is there was a colony of
Valyrian slaves that was being taken
somewhere when they were out at sea they
mutiny took those ships sailed all the
way up around to where Braavos is now
and developed their city in secret and
they remained a secret city for a long
time before they emerge to the world and
by that time they had established the
iron bank they become very wealthy it's
very insular culture the way Sansa talks
about the North being mistrustful of
outsiders people that aren't northerners
it was the same way with those original
Braavosi but from those original slaves
you have people that founded the iron
bank
you had faceless men he had all the
other beginnings of the facets of
Braavosi culture like the water dancers
like Syrio Forel --is number-8 arya
versus the troupe of actors she has to
kill fake Queen Cersei but the real
drama is her having to watch the first
couple seasons of the show reenacted on
stage her father being beheaded her
sister being abused so the fun of this
is the metaphor of what's going on like
the drama of the actors in what it says
about what's going on over in Westeros
right now with the people that those
characters are playing so she has to
assassinate Queen Cersei because the
actors whose playing Sansa thinks that
she's better so she wants to get rid of
Queen Cersei so that she can play the
Queen so you can kind of see how that's
a metaphor for what might be happening
in A Song of Ice and Fire
aria clearing the path for Sansa to rise
but right now she's just dealing with
the actors I don't know if the wheels in
her head have started to turn yet
because she doesn't know exactly what's
been happening in Westeros she just
knows that her sister is at the mercy of
Joffrey and Cersei she probably knows
that Joffrey's dead but she might not be
up on everything that's happening right
now especially what's happening with
Sansa let me know in the comments though
do you think that her killing this
version of Queen Cersei so that Sansa
can rise says something about what might
be happening later in the story to the
actual real-life versions of these
characters but just so much fun just
because you get so excited the idea like
oh does this
that aria is going to try and kill Queen
Cersei eventually cross her name off our
list that'd be amazing but I almost
forgot this is actually something from
the books it's from a sample chapter
from winds the winter George R Martin
releases sample chapters a couple times
a year this troupe of actors is from
winds of winter number seven another
huge one this was like one of the big
twists of the episode bran learns the
true origin of the White Walkers so just
explain Fran's traveling to the past
he's seeing the origin of the first
night's king at some point during the
war against the first men so there were
a couple different wars in Westeros it's
a pretty normal thing for Westeros to be
in total chaos with itself so the first
men migrated to Westeros the children of
the forest at that time inhabited all of
Westeros there were weirwoods all the
way up and down the land the first men
invaded they got into a big war
eventually there was a truce the first
men settled in the south the children of
the forest migrated to the north and
they were at peace until the Andals
later invaded so then the Andals had a
war with the first men and then even
later than that Aegon the Conqueror came
in and you have what looks like the
Seven Kingdoms of today so there have
been countless Wars I'm actually going
to do a separate video to explain every
major conflict in Westeros see history
there are so many but the thing that the
TV show hasn't done yet I mean we're
only five episodes in so we might see
more of it is that the change from the
books is that the children of the forest
have very powerful magic as we've seen
but part of the reason why they were
able to stop the war against the first
men is because they shattered the arm of
Dorne with the hammer of waters they had
a truce on a special island it looks
like the TV show isn't doing any of that
it's just simplifying and saying the
children of the forest created the White
Walkers to stop the war a weapon of mass
destruction that they lost control of so
you can think of all kinds of real-world
nuclear proliferation parallels here so
now we know that the long night is just
collateral damage from the war against
the first men it was completely
unintentional and now the children of
the forest are dying off at the hands of
the night's king the person that they
created so you can also think of this as
a cautionary tale about having children
thinking about having a child yeah
you'll probably lose control of them at
some point and then they'll kill you in
the books they talk about the 13th Lord
Commander becoming the first night's
king so it seems like they're changing a
few things from
the books there's a video I did right
before the season started so I'll put a
link to it in the description because
there's actually a lot of white Walker
history just not this much like this has
officially pushed into territory that's
beyond what George Martin has written
but number six the Kingsmoot another
huge plot point from the books this was
a little closer to the way it happened
in the books but a couple of changes too
so the Kingsmoot is pretty much the way
you see it it's kind of a farce of an
election
you're on Greyjoy just rides right in
and says you suck I'm gonna be king give
it to me yeah I totally killed my
brother
he's a total boss the actor's
performance was amazing but the thing
that they've changed from the books is
confirmed that euron greyjoy was the one
that killed Balon we don't know that yet
it's still a mystery as to who killed
him and when he rides up to the
Kingsmoot the way he gets everyone's
attention is by blowing a giant Valyrian
horn called dragon binder it implies
he's going to bend Daenerys his dragons
to his will it's a horn for controlling
dragons but the other big changed the
thousand ships that he's going to take
to Daenerys to try and marry her he
actually sends Victarion so they're
basically giving all the Victorians
storyline to Iran but it is a really big
book than Kingsmoot and you're on trying
to woo Daenerys to form an alliance if
you're really big on book history - you
could think of Euron Greyjoy and
Daenerys thousand ships is like a
callback - Nymeria 'he's ten thousand
ships the ancient warrior queen Nymeria
founded Dorne she came over she brought
her people over in ten thousand ships so
there was a book written about her
called the ten thousand ships so think
of her is like a cross between Daenerys
if she was more like Lady Brienne like
an actual sword wielding warrior queen
so anyone that's named Nymeria like
Nymeria sand
Nymeria the direwolf they're named after
that original badass warrior queen
number four Daenerys takes her new army
back to marine so I like the way the
Dothraki are just like alright you're
the new boss we'll go where you want us
to go let's do it and she sends Jorah
way it's this really touching scene
he admits you know I do love you Tyrion
was right so the real question now is
will he actually be able to find a cure
or will he just tried to come back and
help her later what I think might end up
happening is is that he'll just forego a
cure like he'll actually look for a
little bit but then you know Daenerys
needs me I'm gonna go back and help her
with the time that I have left I feel
like at the rate of progression he could
survive
to the end of season 8 but they're
speeding things along so we'll just have
to wait and see but I feel like it's
okay to be hopeful about Jorah Stannis
was able to cure Shireen's greyscale but
the circumstances were vastly different
he caught it
immediately and he had unlimited money
to bring healers to him Jorah has none
of those things but number three this is
actually so much fun
Varys versus the High Priestess so I
feel like this might be away Daenerys
will learn about the war for the dawn
but when she was explaining to Varys
about the voice and the flames that made
me think who Varys was probably talking
to the red God or the red God was
speaking to him and there's this weird
thing that was going on in the episode
let me know if you guys picked up on it
too the way they were talking about the
children creating the White Walkers the
way the High Priestess was interpreting
the prophecy Daenerys is the prince who
was promised she didn't use gender when
she was talking about it she said the
one who was promised which is actually
truer to the original Valyrian version
of the prophecy but then jaqen was
invoking the idea of the many-faced God
it's all the same to the many-faced God
he doesn't only come for the wicked so I
did a double-take during the episode I'm
like wait a minute
are they trying to tell us that this is
all the same God it's all connected and
all related so I'll say up to this point
in the books they presented most of the
gods as separate entities when they talk
about the red God they talk about him
existing in a constant state of battle
with the great other the person that the
White Walkers serve but if the White
Walkers squirt created by the children
of the forest does that mean the
children of the forest also worship the
great other so they're starting to mix a
lot of ideas together and it's making me
think that there's a level of
connectedness that we haven't really
thought about before there have been
people that have said you know what if
all these gods are just the same God and
people are misinterpreting things that
was a big runner during that High
Priestess explainer she said people make
mistakes she was talking about
Melisandre but the idea applies to
everything on the show so that's really
the mind trip I feel like people were
like kind of thrown off by the Hodor
reveal like this will blow your mind but
the way they're talking about the gods
the origin the White Walkers the great
other the red God that I feel will be
the bigger mind trip this season and I
feel like that will require a George R
Martin clarification like yes I intended
it to be this way in my books or no this
is absolutely different from the
direction that I'm taking things in the
books so let me know in the comments do
you feel like
they're going to say that all of these
things are connected there's only one
God or do you still believe that there
are many different gods I just I feel
like there's a reason why jaqen H'ghar
keeps saying the name the many-faced God
he keeps saying that out loud over and
over number two brand versus the night's
king he's able to grab brand in his
flashback as he's projecting himself
astrally into the past so this is where
it gets a little confusing because you
wonder about the mechanics of it but I
feel like he's only able to do this
because the night's king is so powerful
and he's connected to brand through
their shared ability because both brands
powers and the Nights Kings powers flow
from the powers that the children of the
forest have so the interpretation that
I'm taking is is that they just they
share a lot in common even though
they're vastly different there are a lot
of powers that the White Walkers
probably have that brand doesn't have
but it explains especially that the
night's king being so powerful it
explains why he would be able to grab
brand in the astral projection just like
the three-eyed Raven would be so I
actually think that's a good comparison
the night's king is every bit as
powerful it has at least equal abilities
if not most of the same abilities is the
three-eyed Raven in the abilities that
bran has but r.i.p three-eyed Raven
r.i.p summer in r.i.p Hodor because
number one WTF hold the door so we
actually learn more about the bleed
ability that bran has they have yet to
explain how strong that is and if you're
confused about what's happening here
bran had worked into Hodor so brain was
simultaneously in proximity to young
Hodor while he was ward into adulthood
or so i think that has something to do
with the connection so we'll have to
wait for a clarification from Dan and
Davis to the interpretation that they
took or from george RR martin or for
someone associated with the production
but it was such a touching payoff from a
big setup earlier this season as well as
a big set up from season 1 episode 1
from that very first episode because
you're like hey there's this big guy
that can always say his name why is the
only sing his name that's kind of funny
we have this meeting with george martin
where we're trying to get as much
information as possible out of him and
probably the most shocking revelation he
had for us was when he told us the
origin of fedora how that name came
about I just remember Danna looking each
other when he said that like holy [ __ ]
so rest in peace Hodor rest in peace
summer three-eyed Raven your sacrifices
are not in vain but let me know in the
comments what was your favorite part of
the episode was that the Hodor reveal
was learning about the White Walkers was
it seeing the Kingsmoot aside from some
of the big reveals overall I think this
is actually my favorite episode it's
such an amazing payoff but just a quick
reminder there's a new round of the
giveaway that starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a [ __ ] on this
video you can leave a comment too please
just leave a comment but I'll totally do
a follow-up QA and I'm gonna wait a day
or two to see about my next bonus video
just to see if there's any clarification
on some of the mechanics of the twists
that they had in the story especially
white Walker children of the force
related that's such a huge deal so
everybody be sure to pour a drink out
for Hodor and summer they will be
avenged while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for a
deeper explainer on brains flashbacks
and the way they're using them this
season on the TV show and you can click
here for last week's episode for video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight